[Musik]
meine letzte reise tappe startete morgen
kurz nach 4
ich bin in einem buddhistischen tempel
in cham yorker in der nähe von kyoto
mein name ist patrick rohr seit vier
wochen bin ich als fotograf und
journalist in japan unterwegs ich bin
dabei ein buch zu machen über dieses
land
[Musik]
ich lerne denn wenn ich kenn show sowie
kennen
er ist ein roter sein weist er führt
einen der wenigen tempel in japan in
denen auch ausländer seien lernen können
ich mache einen kreis und den stein
du machst den äußeren in familie dazu
darum alle menschen sind verblasst sein
öffnet das herz
nichts ist für die ewigkeit
ich kann ein neues muster machen wenn
ich wählen jede tätigkeit ist in sich
perfekt wenn man die ganze energie auf
den augenblick lenkt das wichtigste ist
dass selbst man wendet sich dem inneren
des selbst zudem waren selbst mit dieser
spirituellen gesunden haltung bringt man
den körper atmung und den geist in
ordnung geist und körper genießen
diese drei punkte zu trainieren
das macht das leben mit 10 aus
[Musik]
es wird zeit für das frühstück
die stäbchen aus gefühle und platziert
sie rechts
dann öffnet die servierten nehmt die
schüsselchen mit der linken hand von
links her francisco ein schüler von
roche game show erklärt uns besuchen aus
dem westen die regeln im sensor nicht
die gedanken ablenken
darum es sogar beim essen alle stränge
ritualisiert jetzt die nächste schüssel
[Musik]
bitte es schneller und still
bitte nicht den rechtlichen essen
legt die stäbchen nicht hin egal was
passiert den rettich reinigt die
stäbchen liegt sie zurück in die hülle
trinkt das wasser
silber das ist die zehn weise zu speisen
alles wird genau und bewusst gemacht das
ist etwas vom wichtigsten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir gehen in einer anderen tempel von
roche king show
[Musik]
hier machen wir eine sie zu meditation
langsam atmen wir ein und wieder aus das
soll uns helfen uns auf das hier und
jetzt zu konzentrieren
so einfach geht das gar nicht
ich frage mich was da droht jeder macht
und ich befürchte dass es mich auf
nächsten trifft tatsächlich
ich übe stehe ist und bin nach dem
langen sitzen plötzlich ziemlich
entspannt das sei ja auch der sinn der
schläger sagte rogen sammelt sich die
kraft beim tandem dem zentrum des
körpers
hier kommt die kraft her sein zentrum
ist schlaf ein tandem sollst du stärken
damit seine willenskraft und energie
fließen kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
denn power ist das spirituelle
bewusstsein mit allem verbunden zu sein
ich zeige dir die innere kraft mit
meinem körper so ist diese ski leichter
zu verstehen und dann sagte roche ich
soll mich auf seinem bauch setzen
wie schwer bist du der rutsche
demonstriert was es heißt wenn man seine
ganze energie in kiel
im zentrum des körpers konzentriert wenn
man richtig atmet und geistig wach wird
man sich seine prächtigen seele bewusst
und entwickelt sich heute nennt man das
auch meint fornas achtsamkeit das
wichtigste band sehen ist sein zentrum
zu finden
tag 1
[Musik]
meine fotos habe ich mir wieder mal ab
verdient und ich habe jetzt zumindest
eine idee was 10 bedeutet
[Musik]
von kyoto geht meine reise weiter nach
osaka die stadt ist ein autos
handelszentrum und heute eines der
wichtigsten industriezentren japans der
hafen von osaka ist eine der wichtigsten
im land
in osaka gefällt es mir ab der ersten
sekunde
die stadt ist sehr lebendig und
irgendwie auch weniger hektisch als
tokio die menschen machen an entspannten
eindruck
[Musik]
unten am fluss treten wieder einmal
junge menschen die berühmt werden
möchten und wie ich so beobachtet wie
die frauen auf der einen und die männer
auf der anderen seite des flusses stehen
denke ich dass das beinahe symbol es ist
für japan
die menschen hier würden sich nämlich
immer weniger binden habe ich gelesen
aus angst eine beziehung einzugehen
würden auch immer mehr leute alleine
leben warum das so ist versuche ich
heute abend in der singles bar eden
herauszufinden
[Musik]
frauen die auf der suche nach einem mann
sind warten in einem eigenen raum wenn
der bahnmanager das gefühl hat eine der
frauen passe zu einem mann bringt sie zu
ihm
ich bitte shingo hatschi so heißt der
manager mich zu einer single frau zu
bringen ohne paarung absicht natürlich
ich würde sie einfach gerne
fotografieren und mit ihr leben
ich darf mich zu juve setzte sie ist ein
und leistung und seit etwas mehr als
einem jahr singen
ist das schwierig für einen mann zu
finden
es ist schwierig den ersten eindruck
richtig einzuschätzen
träumen sie von einer familie mit
kindern
zwei wären perfekt
sind sie nervös an einem solchen abend
ja ich bin aufgeregt
bahn-manager shingo kommt wieder für
zwei frauen am nebentisch hatte zwei
passende männer gefunden
25 minuten lässt er die frauen und
männer beinamen besetzen
spätestens dann sollte man wissen ob man
sich nochmal treffen möchte oder nicht
wenn man es dann nicht weiß wird es
sowieso nicht sagt man hier der erste
eindruck ist entscheidend wenn die zeit
rum ist tauscht man entweder
telefonnummern aus oder geht zurück zum
manager der gibt einem dann ein feedback
zum treffen wie eine art liebes coach
[Musik]
bernd die vier hier an wandeln setze ich
mich zu den drei männern im abteil
daneben seien auf der suche nach liebe
jemand zum heiraten ja heiraten ja
möglicherweise schüchtern
ja wir sind japaner yuki es ist immer
noch alleine
[Musik]
wenn manager shingo nicht wirklich das
gefühl hat es könnte etwas geben bringt
er seine gäste nicht mit anderen
zusammen
yuki gibt auf dieses wochenende wird sie
vermutlich werde alleine verbringen
[Musik]
warum haben sie heute abend keinen mann
gefunden will erkennen warum wohl
heutzutage ist es schwieriger jemanden
am arbeitsplatz kennen zu lernen
der viel über stunden hat man kaum zeit
leute zu treffen und solche orte wie
hier gehören zu den wenigen
gelegenheiten denken
juni ist gekommen weil sie von freunden
gehört hat die hier früher einmal ihren
partner gefunden haben und sie ist auch
schon wieder zurückkommt platz der mann
den sie getroffen hat habe zwar eine
gute ausstrahlung aber irgendwie habe es
nicht richtig gepasst ihr seid
konversation sehr wichtig und in diesem
gespräch habe es einfach zu viele pausen
gegeben
das erzählte manager shingo der jetzt in
seiner rolle als coach war hier ist was
haben sie von managing gelernt
[Musik]
angst hat auf das äußere zu schauen
sollte ich auf meine gefühle für diese
person achten gefühle sind wichtiger als
das aussehen
[Musik]
shingo welchen rat würden sie
japanischen männern geben und welche
japanischen frauen männer tauschen zwar
die kontaktinformationen aus aber sie
sind zu tollpatschig in der darauf
folgenden kommunikation frauen urteilen
viel zu schnell
frauen müssten sich nach diesen treffen
mindestens noch zu einem dinner
verabredet und zu dem man noch ein
bisschen besser kennen lernen
bis vor nicht allzu langer zeit gab es
in japan vor allem arrangierte
hochzeiten
liebesheiraten waren selten das ist
heute anders
aber mit der freiheit sind auch die
ansprüche gestiegen scheint mir und
vielleicht auch die überforderung
[Musik]
einen großen modernisierungsschub japan
in den 1970 er wissen 1 10 jahren
gemacht
in diesen jahren ist auch die wirtschaft
regelrecht explodiert aber trotz aller
veränderungen in der japanischen
gesellschaft hat die tradition ihren
stellenwert behalten
in einem ruhigen viertel von osaka
treffe ich ja sotschi er beherrscht ein
jahrhunderte altes handwerk kasumi
geschnitzten masken für das no theater
das ist eine 700 jahre autotheater
folgen die sich bis heute praktisch
nicht verändert hat alle rollen werden
von männern gespielt
was für eine figur assist erkennt man an
den masken sie sind das zentrale element
des no theaters je nachdem wie der
schauspieler den kopf hält verändert
sich der gesichtsausdruck der masken
[Musik]
humor es bedeutet der maske einen
traurigen ausdruck zu verleihen
und wenn man sie so nach oben richtet
dann bekommt sie einen helleren ausdruck
ein beispiel
hier habe ich ein gesicht auf das
gefaltete papier gezeichnet so etwas
ähnliches macht man auch mit der note
[Musik]
ich würde ja sotschi gerne für mein buch
fotografieren am liebsten mit
natürlichem licht damit man die schöne
stimmung in seinem atelier auch auf den
bildern gut sieht der mann beeindruckt
mich die 15 jahre lang ging er in die
lehre und erst nach zehn jahren durfte
er zum ersten mal selber einem
abgeschnitten und auch nach 40 jahren in
denen er sein handwerk nun ausführt
machte seine arbeit immer noch mit
großer hingabe
ich habe den letzten wochen auf unserer
reise gelernt dass man in japan sein
wahres gesicht nicht zeigt wie stark
denken sie herrn matschie dass jetzt
diese neue kunst findet es ja typisch
japanisches auch ist sein wahres gesicht
zu verbergen
[Musik]
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man so
direkt an den bezug herstellen kann
zwischen nun dieser japanischen
gewohnheit aber es gab einen historisch
wichtigen spieler dessen lehre lautete
man soll etwas nicht aktiv explizite
erstellen sondern implizit spüren zum
beispiel gibt es beim auftreten auf der
bühne eine haltung bei der die maske
einen bestimmten winkel hat wenn man
diesen winkel auch nur ganz sanft
verändert wird etwas ausgedrückt
darstellungsweise ist also sehr
eingeschränkt es ist wie so oft in japan
wo vieles nicht gesagt wird sondern man
spüren fühlen muss um zu verstehen
[Musik]
unschön
würden sie für mich eine solche maske
fast gesicht hat und die fertige maske
100 stunden arbeitet ja sotschi an eine
maske das wichtigste sei sagt er dass
jede maske eine perfekte kopie ihre
vorgänger nennen ist künstlerische
freiheit eine neue interpretation das
gibt es nicht in der kunst
[Musik]
natürlich würde ich die masken erste
auch noch gern im einsatz sehen ja
sotschi vermittelt mir einen besuch im
kongo no theater
[Musik]
hiroshi kongo für das theater in
sechsundzwanzigster generation seine
vorfahren haben es von über 650 jahren
gegründet ich kann nicht viel gesehen
die maske muss ich gut polstern weil ich
sie stundenlang tragen diese maske ist
über 300 jahre shikongo behandelt sie
wie einen schatz
sein sohn dazu noch der das theater war
in 27 generation führen wird verwandelt
sich gerade in eine junge frau
es ist nur für eine probe aber trotzdem
sehr aufwändig
[Musik]
die tradition sagt in dem moment in dem
der spieler die maske aufsetzt förther
geist der figuren
[Musik]
das no theaters streng organisiert jede
bewegung ist genau festgelegt seit
jahrhunderten
[Musik]
sie verstecken ihr gesicht hinter einer
maske müssen ihr gesicht verstecken
hinter einer maske wird dafür ein
schauspieler nicht etwas ganz wichtiges
[Musik]
es gibt auch rollen bei welchen man
keine maske getragen wird
aber auch dort muss die mimik des
schauspielers neutral bleiben das wird
unter maske genannt das eigene gesicht
wird dann gewissermaßen als maske
getragen fühlen werden also nie über die
mimik ausgedrückt es ist eher etwas das
aus den tiefen inneren heraus kommt
[Musik]
eine faszinierende theater vor allen die
ich nicht ganz verstehen aber ich bin
beeindruckt von ihrer eleganz
[Musik]
von osaka viel geld nach okinawa die
haupt im kkl einer ganzen gruppe von
kleinen inseln ungefähr 1200 km weiter
südlich
[Musik]
das klima in china war ist tropisch
ich habe mich beim ruf angemeldet denn
works on organic farms übersetzt den
freiwilligen helfern hat bio höfen
das bedeutet ich gehe arbeiten und darf
dafür kostenlos beim bauen wohnen
die begrüßung bei einer gastfamilie ist
stürmisch
doch außer dem hund scheint niemand hier
zu zeigen
[Musik]
ich habe dann richtig überhaupt gefunden
ich freue mich sie kennenzulernen
ich bin mir gefällt es hier im dschungel
akiko sagt sie seien vor 13 jahren von
der hauptinsel nach okinawa gezogen ihr
gefalle es ihr besser aus auf estland
japan
die menschen seien offener und
entspannter sie haben ein zimmer für
gäste normalerweise haben wir jeweils
eine person dieses unkraut musst du
schneiden gibt es gefährliche tiere
[Musik]
deshalb machst du am besten so bevor du
anfängst danke los geht's
mit einer kleinen rostigen sichel umkehr
schneiden in der feucht waren und
tropischen hitze mein abendessen
verdiene ich mit hart
[Musik]
meine gastgeber sind keine richtigen
bauen akiko ist ursprünglich juristin
arbeitet aber nicht mehr auf dem beruf
oman abu dis keramikkünstler er wollte
vor allem wegen des guten lebens nach
okinawa kommen
[Musik]
der boden ist nicht nur wegen des lebens
sehr gut ist auch ziemlich fruchtbar das
unkraut jedenfalls musketieren wie
verrückt
[Musik]
die jammers sind wie viele menschen auf
okinawa selbstversorger als abschluss
für eine gartenarbeit steche ich noch
die feelings wiegeln aus china haben
vier kinder zwei leben noch zu hause das
ist das okinawa küchengerät schiri
chilli wie heißt das ich gebe mir große
mühe richtig zu benutzen
erstmals ohne blutvergießen
du kannst auf kann ich den rest essen ja
ja
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich liebe die japanische küche
sie ist sehr leicht und das ist frisch
und mit einem guten sagte dazu dem
japanischen reiswein gibt es auch gute
gespräche erzählt mir von der
schwierigen geschichte von okinawa
sie sagt die menschen hier würden sich
als opfer fühlen früher war es ein
eigenständiges königreich dann wurde es
für japan annektiert und die menschen
verloren ihre identität japan gegen
japan hatten china war immer
diskriminiert und opa war im zweiten
weltkrieg der einzige ort wo ein land
gekämpft wurde
die amerikaner haben nicht auf der
hauptinsel gekämpft sie gingen nicht
nach tokio
sie haben es nur bombardiert die
amerikaner haben dann für ihre militär
basen den einheimischen land weggenommen
und sind geblieben
neben der geschichte fühlen sich die
menschen auf okinawa doppelt als opfer
betrogen und benutzt so fühlt sich vor
allem die ältere generation
wegen dieser empfindung proteste die
ältere generation gegen die us präsenz
aber es ändert sich nichts
der tag fing ganz harmlos mit
unplatzierten an und endet politisch
spannend
[Musik]
die geschichte mit dem protest lässt mir
keine ruhe
ganz hinten er soll eine gruppe
demonstranten den bau einer us-basis
blockieren china coal mine übersetzerin
weiß mehr
heute morgen ist die polizei bereits vor
ort in einer halben stunde wird sie
beginnen den platz zu räumen
ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen
auseinandersetzungen mit der polizei im
friedlichen japan
eine demonstration in einem land in dem
man normalerweise seine meinung nicht
sagt das ist doch sehr außergewöhnlich
[Musik]
die sicherheitsleute der militärbasis
sind zurückhaltend sie kennen die
demonstranten ein paar berlin machen das
seit 20 jahren
dann kommen zwei polizisten sie wollen
wissen was sie da machen sie stellen
sich mit visitenkarte vor bedanken sich
für die auskunft und verabschieden sich
freundlich doch dann fährt die polizei
über das geschütz auf
so geht das jeden tag die polizei löste
die demonstration auf damit die
lastwagen endlich auf die baustelle
können jede minute die die amerikaner
nicht weiterbauen können kostet geld und
das ist genau das was die demonstranten
wollen sie wollen die amerikaner von der
insel vertreiben weil das immer wieder
gewaltsame übergriffe durch soldaten
gibt weil diese auch die natur kaputt
machen würden und weil die menschen auf
okinawa angst haben sie könnten
plötzlich das ziel von angriffen sein
nordkorea ist nicht weit entfernt die
menschen auf dieser insel haben schon
viel durchgemacht davon kann frauen die
ganz alten menschen auf okinawa erzählen
und von ihnen gibt es hier viele
auf okinawa gibt es nämlich dass durch
das 100-jährige es heißt
und da sollen die ältesten menschen der
welt leben
ich treffe hanami ag
sie ist 93 und mutter von zehn kindern
hanna hat den zweiten weltkrieg
miterlebt als die amerikaner okinawa
erobert hatten
was halten sie von den entwicklungen der
letzten jahrzehnte in japan und china
war unter der kontrolle der japanischen
regierung waren wir immer arm
seit die amerikaner hier sind sind wir
reiche ja ich bin dankbar und glücklich
dass sie uns beschützen
jeden tag züchtig unter anderem goya das
typische gesunde gemüse hier entferne
die insekten und schnecken aus meinem
garten das ist mein morgendliches
fitnesstraining
[Gelächter]
was denken sie über die jungen leute
heutzutage gehen alle gleichen spital
wenn sie ein wenig fieber hat meine zehn
kinder waren nie im spital
wir hatten kein geld für so ich möchte
ihnen ein getränk mit wildkräutern und
zucker das hängt das fieber das fieber
gilt auch wenn man bananenblätter
ausgelegt wie ein kissen machten werde
das leben auf okinawa ändert sich wie
überall in japan nicht nur wegen des
einflusses aus dem westen aber auch
traditionen gehen verloren
alles ist gemüse
[Gelächter]
na gut
[Musik]
ich esse das immer
[Gelächter]
dass die leute hier in ogni so alt
werden hat verschiedene gründe
das gesunde essen ist eine aber auch das
klima und die gute soziale vernetzung
dort fahren einen großen einfluss einmal
pro woche treffen sich die ältesten
frauen der welt im gemeindezentrum von
kimi hanami ag und ihre freundinnen
können hier auch ihre gesundheit checken
lassen dass die frauen enorm ihn nicht
nur als sondern auch gesund werden
könnte damit zusammenhängen dass man
hier auf der insel nach dem grundsatz
haare hat überlebt hat ivo heißt für
deinen bauch nur zu 80 prozent mehr sei
ungesund sagt moniert
sprichst du verstehst du japan
als ich jung war war ich sehr hübsch und
meine haut war wunderschön so alt bin
ich jetzt ich bin jetzt 90 du schwitzt
nicht trocknet ich etwas ab mit dem
taschentuch
ich bin fotograf gut dass michalkow
miyake daran erinnert ich sollte er noch
arbeiten verlautete herzlichkeit hat
sich das fast vergessen
[Musik]
was für eine zeit den kino ganz ehrlich
der abschied fällt mir nicht leicht
[Musik]
ich gehe trotzdem weiter weiter richtung
süden noch einmal 430 kilometer und zwar
auf die insel ishigaki ganz in der nähe
von taiwan
[Musik]
hier besuchen tomohiro hat mir gesagt
dieser mann hätte eine ganz besondere
geschichte
das sind traditionelle boote die ganz
aus holz gemacht sind und da gibt es
keine metall schrauben oder nägel wenn
du metall nagel verwendest werden die
nach 10 20 jahren rostig und es bildet
sich einmal rundherum der nagel wird
lose und fällt raus
ein bambus stift hingegen wird eins mit
dem holz des bootes solange das ganze
holz hält kannst das boot benutzen wenn
ein stück bricht kann ich es heraussägen
und ein neues stück einfügen
[Musik]
der tumor kommt ursprünglich aus tokio
dort arbeitete er in ganz verschiedenen
berufen aber richtig zufrieden waren
irgendwann wurde ihm alles zu viel und
er beschloss mit seiner familie nach
kanada auszuwandern
[Musik]
hier lernte tomohiro einen alten
bootsbauer kennen er war 82 und wollte
sich langsam zurückziehen tomohiro war
von der traditionellen handwerkskunst
sofort fasziniert und laute boots macher
zeigte mir selber sabani bauen kann
endlich hatte tomohiro seine bestimmung
gefunden
[Musik]
die sunset beach
hier liegt oma heroes eigenes sawani
verankern
[Musik]
normalerweise für tomohiro mit
touristengruppen aufs meer
heute will die schnorchel gehen
[Musik]
hat sich dein leben verändert sagt durch
ihr liebster während ich in tokio
arbeitete um eine familie zu ernähren
versteifte sich meine innere haltung ich
merkte ich arbeite um zu überleben ohne
arbeit kein leben ohne geld keine ahnung
er auf ishigaki änderte sich meine
mentalität dann langsam
es funktioniert auch anders und einfache
von der natur und warum erhält man ja
wasser und man gar nahrung anbauen damit
an essen und überleben kann
die dinge sind da und du kannst anfangen
zu leben und hast zeit für die familie
was muss ich wissen bevor ich ins wasser
springen macht druckausgleich wenn du
kannst du das
[Musik]
judith
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich verstehe was tomohiro meint wenn er
sagt er habe hier mit seiner frau und
den beiden kindern das paradies gefunden
dass sohn ist schon größer tochter oder
lebt noch bei den eltern
ist hier auf ishigaki geboren
es gibt kaum einschränkungen wir können
unsere familien selber gestalten
nachbarn sind wie eine erweiterte
familie wir sind glücklich
[Musik]
wer nicht das wichtigste hast du heute
zwar weniger aber dein leben ist viel
besser als früher da steht
ich finde im glück hinten vom anhäufen
von vielen dingen ab fokus wie mache ich
mein leben reicher wie kann ich eine
tiefere erfüllung finden mit dem was ich
habe
das mache man viel glücklicher
ich zog vor bald sechs wochen los um mit
meiner fotokamera japan zu entdecken auf
eine art wie man es sonst nicht kennt
mein ziel war ein buch zu machen über
dieses land seine gegensätze ich bin so
vielen verschiedenen menschen begegnet
wie ich es nie erwartet hätte
sie haben ja einblick gegeben in erleben
japan wird mir vermutlich trotzdem immer
fremd bleiben
aber ich verstehe es nach dieser reise
schon ein bisschen besser und ich weiss
ich möchte auf jeden fall wiederkommen
irgendwo tief in mir drin hat dieses
land haben diese menschen etwas in mir
berührt
[Musik]